[Music]
you know who hates wine oxygen if you go
by the evidence at least because nothing
kills an open bottle like exposure - OH
- what you need is another gas to
displace the oxygen and a way to keep it
in that's the idea behind the Corvin
1001 Sabre a small needle slides into
the cork and then lets you pour press
the button and a canister attached to it
replaces the air in the bottle with
inert argon gas no oxidation see now you
can find out if that legacy bottle is
ready to open or still needs some time
to rest in your no doubt extensive
temperature controlled wine cellar or
your kitchen cabinet it's a bit pricey
at an estimated $350 but so is the wine
you're probably using it with just make
sure the bottle you're drinking has a
real cork composite clerks won't reseal
will save this bottle for later
[Music]